[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna ustedes Les agradecemos
su sintonía vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
Estados Unidos descartó que la colisión
entre uno de sus drones y un avión de
combate ruso sobre el mar Negro fuese un
accidente esto luego de que Rusia negara
su responsabilidad en los hechos y
asegurara que el aparato entró en un
vuelo descontrolado con pérdida de
altura y chocó contra el agua analizamos
en esta emisión
la inflación interanual en Argentina
llegó a 102,5% es la más alta en 31 años
así lo informó el Instituto Nacional de
estadística Y censos que además Indicó
que en febrero el índice de precios al
consumidor subió un 6% respecto a enero
preocupa la subida en los precios de los
alimentos que fue de 9,8% Tenemos
reporte desde Buenos Aires
se cumplen cinco años del asesinato de
la diputada brasileña Mariela Franco un
crimen que tras un lustro sigue sin ser
resuelto Este martes familiares y
simpatizantes le rindieron homenaje
Tenemos reporte desde Río de Janeiro
[Música]
damos inicio en el mar Negro donde según
Estados Unidos un caza ruso golpeó un
dron de vigilancia del ejército
estadounidense lo que provocó que se
estrellara contra el mar las fuerzas de
Washington aseguraron que el incidente
siguió un patrón de comportamiento
peligroso por parte de los pilotos rusos
quienes antes de la colisión habrían
arrojado combustible sobre el dron mq9 y
volaron frente a él en maniobras
inseguras el embajador ruso en la
capital estadounidense Fue llamado a
consultas por su parte Moscú negoció
implicación en los hechos y aseguró que
Estados Unidos tuvo que derribar su
propio dron luego de que entrara en un
vuelo descontrolado con pérdida de
altura lo que lo llevó a colisionar
contra el agua para analizar información
conectamos con Carlos Cuevas él es
teniente coronel retirado del ejército
de Estados Unidos y experto en asuntos
militares Bienvenido a France 24 Cuál es
la función de este tipo de drones Y por
qué razones podría caer en un vuelo
descontrolado que lo lleve a estrellarse
como lo Afirma Rusia
el objetivo de este tipo de dron es
obtener información todo el mundo habla
de los millones de dólares que Estados
Unidos le ha dado a Ucrania y la otan en
términos generales y hablan de la de los
armamentos y en muchas ocasiones olvidan
el apoyo de inteligencia este drone se
encarga de ese aspecto de recopilar
inteligencia de distintos movimientos
dentro del mar Negro en este caso en
particular muy improbable de que se haya
ido en un patrón de vuelo de controlado
ya que estos estos drones están muy bien
controlados y habrá que esperar a que se
hagan público si se hace pública de
alguna manera información adicional
sobre el la colisión que informa hoy
Washington viendo este panorama se
pueden esperar más sanciones de
Washington a Moscú
hemos visto ya que se han tomado pasos
diplomáticos en el frente diplomático
como muy bien reportaron hace unos
minutos llamaron al al representante
diplomático de moco en Washington y le y
le hicieron verdad un reclamo a nivel
diplomático lo mismo ocurrió en en Moscú
No creo que en este momento haya otros
otras acciones otros pasos por los
ejemplos a nivel militar creo que se
tratarán de utilizar otros elementos de
los instrumentos de poder que tiene
Estados Unidos pero sin duda la
situación pues trae una atención
adicional entre Rusia y Estados Unidos
con telón de fondo la Guerra de Ucrania
justamente le pregunto por este hecho
porque este choque entre las partes
podría de alguna manera influir en la
guerra
el hecho de que este drone estuviera
allí como dije anteriormente parte del
apoyo en la recolección de inteligencia
en apoyo al al ejército ucraniano hay
que ver Yo creo que es muy temprano no
creo yo que vaya a ocurrir algo en
términos de que vayan a moverse tropas
de Estados Unidos
yo creo que la reacción de Estados
Unidos va a ser enviar otro otro dron y
inmediatamente ya con mucha probabilidad
está en el aire y y continuar el apoyo
para enviar de esa manera el mensaje de
que no van a ser intimidados y que van a
continuar en aguas internacionales
apoyando Ucrania yo creo que eso es lo
que vamos a ver y tendríamos que ver
entonces si o vuelve a ocurrir Cómo
sería la reacción de Washington el señor
Cuevas a usted muchas gracias por su
análisis por compartirlo con nosotros en
France 24
un placer estar aquí seguimos hablando
de Estados Unidos porque el presidente
Joe biden promulgó una nueva orden
ejecutiva que busca aumentar la
verificación de antecedentes para poder
adquirir un arma de fuego la medida
también Busca promover el almacenamiento
seguro del armamento estas fueron sus
palabras
primero esta orden ejecutiva ayuda a
mantener las armas de fuego lejos de las
manos peligrosas mientras sigo pidiendo
al congreso que exija la comprobación de
antecedentes para todas las ventas de
armas de fuego y mientras tanto mi orden
ejecutiva ordena el fiscal general que
tome todas las medidas legales para
acercarnos lo más posible a la
verificación Universal de antecedentes
sin una nueva legislación es de sentido
común comprobar si alguien es un
delincuente o un abusador doméstico
antes de comprar un arma
ahora cambiamos de tema y vamos a
Argentina donde la crisis económica
afecta cada vez más el poder adquisitivo
de los ciudadanos el Instituto Nacional
de estadística y censos informó que el
índice de precios al consumidor registró
un alza mensual de 6,6% en febrero de
2023 y por primera vez en más de tres
décadas la inflación interanual del país
se ubicó en tres dígitos llegando al
102,5%. natalio cosoy corresponsal de
France 24 nos dio más detalles desde
Buenos Aires
me gustaría mencionar una una cuestión
ese aumento del 6,6% Fue de más del 7%
en las zonas del noreste y el Noroeste
argentino que son las más pobres del
país y es muy importante destacar que de
todos los rubros que aumentaron el
aumento mayor de 9,8% a nivel nacional
fue en alimentos y bebidas durante
muchos meses el año pasado el aumento
había sido por ejemplo en textiles en
ropas en calzado que son elementos
productos de los que uno puede esperar
para hacer la compra pero en alimentos
es clave y afecta especialmente a los
sectores más pobres Así que este
incremento es clave además fue
arrastrado sobre todo por la carne la
carne vacuna que venía con un acuerdo de
precios a fin del año 2022 ese acuerdo
Se terminó y tras el acuerdo de precios
efectivamente Bueno un empujón en el
precio en el precio de la carne así que
muy dura la situación para los
argentinos especialmente como te decía
los sectores más pobres del país
vamos a Río de Janeiro porque se
cumplieron cinco años del asesinato de
la diputada brasileña Mariela Franco su
crimen Todavía no se ha resuelto pero
los habitantes del centro de esta ciudad
decidieron realizar un festival
reivindicativo en su honor Valeria
sacone corresponsal de France 24 nos
trae los detalles
[Aplausos]
han pasado cinco años desde que la
concejala negra Mariel y Franco fue
brutalmente asesinada aquí en Río de
Janeiro cinco años después sus
familiares y la sociedad civil se
preguntan Quién fue el mandante de este
asesinato y cuál fue la razón
[Música]
cada día que pasa nuestro dolor aumenta
no conseguimos hacer el luto este luto
del que precisamos después de cinco años
las autoridades Río de Janeiro tienen
que dar estas respuestas no solo para mí
como madres sino también para los
electores de Mariel la familia y el
Brasil que clama por la justicia social
porque eso es lo que María
[Música]
yo conocí personalmente a Mariel hoy yo
siento que ella me representó de verdad
mucha gente que conozco la conocía la
amaban Yo hoy estoy aquí para apoyar
esta causa para saber Quién mató a
Mariel Franco
tras el cambio de gobierno la policía
pagará ha abierto una nueva línea de
investigación recordamos que la hermana
de María Daniel y Franco hoy es ministra
de Walter racial en el gobierno Lula por
esta razón la familia espera ahora
obtener respuestas sobre los autores
intelectuales de ese atentado y también
que por fin se celebre el juicio contra
los únicos dos arrestados considerados
los autores materiales del asesinato y
en Ciudad Juárez en México decenas de
migrantes esperan poder llegar a Estados
Unidos después de que el domingo cientos
de personas intentarán cruzar la
frontera masivamente sin éxito esto
fruto de la frustración generada por la
falta de atención en el proceso de asilo
lanzado por el presidente Joe biden Alba
Santana nos amplía
frustración y mucho cansancio son los
sentimientos de los migrantes retenidos
en Ciudad Juárez localidad fronteriza
entre México y Estados Unidos yo las
uñas de los pies mío caminando toda la
selva y todo donde todo lado porque
supuestamente El emigrante no le pueden
dar cola El emigrante no lo pueden
ayudar en ningún lado y emigrar no es un
delito allí muchos pasaron a la noche en
refugios antes de intentar cruzar a
Estados Unidos y acusaron a malos tratos
por parte de las autoridades mexicanas y
falta de protección en general Nosotros
somos seres humanos
lo que procuramos es este que tengan
vaya que tengan un lugar seguro que
tengan un este
un espacio donde donde puedan estar a
salvo todo apenas dos días después de
que cientos de migrantes intentaran
cruzar en la frontera masivamente tras
rumores de que se permitiría su entrada
a suelo estadounidense Pero la realidad
que encontraron o fue muy diferente a la
esperada agentes con escudos abarricadas
Y alambre de Espino
por favor queremos respuestas la
aplicación no nos ha servido para
absolutamente nada
viejo
me encuentro
Y es que muchos como Camila Cruz llevan
hasta seis meses esperando una cita para
solicitar asilo en Estados Unidos
acusando que el proceso de asilo que el
presidente Joe biden lanzó en enero
pensado para garantizar la seguridad de
los migrantes tiene carencias la pobreza
y la violencia en sus países de origen
lleva a que unas 200.000 personas
intenten cruzar la frontera hacia
Estados Unidos cada mes en los
territorios palestinos decenas de
jóvenes han formado pequeños brigadas
armadas para realizar ataques en contra
del ejército israelí en enero uno de los
miembros de estos grupos intentó sin
éxito atacar un restaurante en Jericó
donde la afluencia de colonos israelíes
es alta las condiciones en las que Esta
generación de jóvenes ha crecido
provocan que vean las armas como la vida
de escape ideal a su complicada
situación el informe es de Max Pérez
Gallardo
las juventudes palestinas marcan el
camino en la blues grupos de jóvenes se
reúnen en brigadas para alzarse en armas
en contra del ejército israelí No
pertenecen directamente a facciones más
grandes como jamás sin embargo colaboran
con ellas para facilitar el control de
territorios y evitar la detección por
autoridades israelíes muchos de los
integrantes han perdido seres queridos
En el conflicto lo que ha causado que en
su imaginar la lucha armada sea la única
salida
estamos todos aquí la brigada al Axa la
alcut y la brigada alcázan han matado a
mis dos hermanos pero todos los que
están aquí son mis hermanos ganaremos
todos los días con cada martes que muere
ganaremos diez en su lugar tan solo en
2023 alrededor de 80 palestinos han
perdido la vida a manos de las fuerzas
armadas israelíes en constantes redadas
además los asentamientos de colonos e
israelíes en territorios palestinos
considerados ilegales por la mayoría de
los estados de la comunidad
internacional provocan Un aumento
constante de las tensiones
no hay miedo miedo de qué de la muerte
Los enfrentamos a ella todos los días
cuando caminamos por la calle nos
enfrentamos a la muerte de qué debería
tener miedo debería llevar mi arma y
enfrentarme al ejército Porque pueden
dispararme mientras estoy en casa
los movimientos nacionalistas palestinos
post han sido liderados históricamente
por jóvenes y estudiantes en la Segunda
intifada del 2000 este sector
poblacional fue un Rebelde protagonista
en las manifestaciones ahora los jóvenes
palestinos cansados de abusos abren la
posibilidad de una tercera Revolución
popular Palestina
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega Armenia Fernández Con toda
la información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]